hey dude
hurry up Joker trailer dropped we don't
have a minute
what is taking himself
[Music]
well like Captain Spaulding but whatever
where are you going the sets back here
just a skinny white guy with a long hair
but no no no you play the Joker in the
Joker's guy special thanks to Tony Gill
for helping us shoot that I'm Greg I'm
John we're gonna watch this joker
trailer you guys ready I'm excited let's
check this out
[Music]
don't labor for feeling are you having
any negative thoughts
[Music]
when I was a little boy and told people
I was going to be convenient everyone
laughed at me Oh super King of Comedy
yeah
[Music]
Swayne
[Music]
is a joke to you
oh wow
Oh Marouane
[Music]
one small thing yeah see Martin Mariner
yeah oh I'm very excited that looks so
damn good it looks very very good we're
so damn good oh and they even got it an
IMAX 70 millimeter wanna watch this dirt
drama and I'm in frame although I mean
the cinematography of it is absolutely
strikingly gorgeous yeah I really love
how this is strongly dealing with mental
health yeah that seems to be its overall
theme especially with its mean Arthur
Fleck Erica oh yeah well and even I was
looking at the IMDB and even the logline
there describes it as sort of a
cautionary tale and I am excited by the
idea that maybe this cool-looking
comic-book character study kind of movie
could maybe actually have some subtext
about mental illness and the lack of
care that sometimes is presented to
people who suffer with it yeah
definitely I mean more than the first
trailer also this heavily feels like
king a condo yeah like people keep
saying économiques taxi driver this
feels like so excited your comedy
especially I elaborated a little bit
more on the relationship he has as Ozzy
beats yeah you know having that having a
girl who takes interested him you know
girlfriend Harris in this trailer yeah
Roman at least he gets her this time
around with in hat and then also you
know I've seen Robert DeNiro
accommodation making fun of him there
it's you're seeing a progression of what
will lead to him eventually cracking and
I love this idea of how his rise of
being a criminal is finally having him
feel like noticed or appreciated Howard
yeah he's got some kind of value or some
kind of purpose and he's inspiring
people like I yeah I like that too the
way the trailer has that weird tonal
clash with the voiceover where he's like
people are starting to notice it yes and
yeah it's got that like ironic
positivity that's so sinister you know
cuz you know
he's just off yes you know and it really
comes like rocking phoenix man he's
really good at playing characters like
this I love that subtle moment where you
see him like we're trying to find a
laugh just somehow you know cuz I've
heard that of you know hey if you if you
smile for ten seconds
that'll automatically up lift your
hormone so you'll be in a better mood
and it might be true actually I are
saying there is I don't know if it's
kind of like drastically switch you from
the press tech joy fix everything
Hey well yeah but there there is
something to that I that a people
sometimes deal I've been there
definitely of just like sometimes we got
a film and I'm like how I'm just not
feeling good today but let me like two
focal warm-ups let me do whatever I can
to try to like let me just start
laughing so I could start to feel like
I'm in a more upbeat mood but I love
watching that shift of him just walk in
the hall doing his Joker laughs and I'm
just switching into seriousness like
he's clearly not feeling it and I love
see that as he rises increment and being
a criminal he's starting to actually
find joy in the darkness I love it I
love it so much one two I wonder you
know they said they're not going off
very many comic book specifics for this
story and I wonder what that's gonna do
to the involvement of Thomas Wayne
because this Alma this might be a
stretch but it almost reminded me of
what happened with the original Batman
movie where they give the Joker like of
origin and it turns out he's involved
with the death of Batman's parents and
now in this movie it looks like Thomas
Wayne is gonna be directly involved
somehow in the I'm pretty sure he's
going to kill Thomas in the formation of
the Joker yeah yeah absolutely
dirty-ass seem like it would happen from
the first trailer and then looked in
here and then especially getting into a
direct conflict we don't know exactly
what we could all fear eyes all day even
if he doesn't kill him maybe we'll see
him order it happen or something I mean
the linking it with the first trailer
when he puts his fingers and Bruce
Wayne's mouth at the Wayne Manor
I just seems like he probably killed
some Thomas away and write that stuff
probably yeah yeah
you would imagine I'm just really
excited to to see because like I didn't
expect that bumper at the Emery's in the
full makeup and both his age and the
Murray Franklin character there and
they're just like yeah yeah here come on
out and call me the Joker but it also
makes sense a little bit more sense as
to how he's going on a on a talk show
yeah because the idea of like pulling
footage online and making fun of a guy
who's like being a failed stand-up comic
or something like I don't know that's
what it looked like to me that Robertson
was making fun of him then he eventually
invites him to come on and perform you
know
yeah and buy online you mean on a VHS
VHS from 1980s when the internet boom
like a paranormal activity 3 whatever
guys I'm pretty good at opening sketch
yeah forgive me for a lapse in Cabul
area there I'm just most excited about
Marc Maron I'm most excited for Marc
Maron the guy who says that comic book
movies are for adult nerds or whatever
nerd baby you nerd my babies yeah
everyone gets so offended but see Marc
Maron engineer a side by side that's
pretty excited that should be the
thumbnail really really call me Joker
love that all right guys well this
trailer gets you more excited can't wait
to get your tickets bet you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell you could
go ahead check us out on patreon where
we do weekly Q&A Stevie show reactions
stream along as many of those shows have
reaction highlights included so are
there to find out the specifics as to
which one's and he does music coverage
weekly before we wrap this up I let
Sierra pitch today shout out to a man
named Gregory Bullock
Gregory me Gregory I know you've kind of
been having a bit of an up-and-down
period as of late sorry to hear about
what you're currently go
but just remember that no matter what
goes on in your life smile every day you
know just keep doing that mask that pain
with false positivity and I guarantee
you you will eventually break on through
to the dark side and you can help other
people smile by shoving your fingers in
their mouths holding their lips up they
say don't build the house on the sand
cause it will eventually sink I say be a
little bit more ambitious than that and
don't listen to people build that house
on that sand build that house wherever
you want on a serious note I I do feel I
do feel for what you're going through
we've talked seriously in messages
hopefully you caught this shout out and
hopefully it is suitable to your needs
right now buddy I love you I love you
and stay vigilant stay watchful only
Greg's know what that means